the average price for gas in the us rose
to over five dollars a gallon recently
for the first time in history
unfortunately the price at the pump is
likely to keep going up market
participants love to say that the cure
for high prices is high prices
but these days the oil market isn't
providing that cure i'm going to explain
how an imbalance between supply and
demand is keeping oil prices high why
that imbalance hasn't been corrected by
the market so far
and what that could mean for oil prices
going forward
as coveted restrictions are lifted and
more people start returning to the
office and taking summer vacations
demand for oil has been picking up steam
that has helped push crude prices to
well over 100 a barrel and gas prices to
a record high the price of oil isn't
directly responsible for the price of
gas though president joe biden is making
the case that a big part of the jump in
prices is the big profits of oil
refiners he sent a letter to seven major
oil companies that said in part since
the beginning of the year refiners
margins for refining gasoline and diesel
have tripled david kelly chief global
strategist at jp morgan funds recently
calculated that oil companies profits on
each gallon of gas were the highest in
history and that's helping turn oil
companies stock prices around after
years of struggles the s p 500 energy
sector has risen by around 50 percent in
2022 while the overall index has sunk by
around 20 percent
now typically in business the best way
for a company to maximize its profits is
to produce more while prices are high
when prices rise companies increase
production that increases supply and
eventually supply outstrips demand and
prices fall but that's not happening
right now in much of the oil sector and
there's a reason after some tough years
including a historic price collapse in
2020 that sent crude prices into
negative territory
u.s oil companies have changed their
approach to business
new securities filings show that top
executives at major publicly traded oil
companies like pioneer natural resources
and occidental petroleum are now being
rewarded for keeping company costs low
and returning cash to shareholders
via stock buybacks and dividends that
new approach has meant less drilling and
more focus on keeping stock prices high
profits flowing and investors happy
according to reporting from my
colleagues ryan d zember and matt
grossman worker shortages and high input
prices have also made drilling less
attractive the change is so widespread
that a recent survey from the dallas fed
asked how high oil prices would need to
get in order for companies to go into
growth mode and almost 30 percent of oil
executives said price didn't matter
around 60 percent of the executives said
that investor pressure to maintain
capital discipline was the primary
reason companies weren't drilling more
despite skyrocketing prices the us is
now the world's top producer of oil so
american companies preferences play a
major role in supply of oil half of all
large firms in the dallas fed survey
said they expect to pump either no more
oil or just 5 more oil between the
fourth quarter of 2021 and the fourth
quarter of 2022 opec the world's largest
consortium of oil-producing countries
has also held back on flooding the
market with oil
russia's war with ukraine and the
resulting sanctions and embargoes on
russian oil have further put a cramp in
supply with supply being held down it
will likely take a fall in demand to
decrease the price of oil and
unfortunately that typically comes with
a recession
oil companies are doing what dreamville
mclute says he notes when you're chasing
after dividends you always check the
price story of my life the way it came
around the first time won't come back to
you twice
that's all for now i'll see you next
time